we felt this coming they've laid the
foundation for it the past two weeks
urban meyer
former coach at florida when tebow was
the star quarterback there but he's not
back as a quarterback he's going to be
back as a tight end guy hasn't played in
the nfl in a regular season game in nine
years and he's gonna be back as a tight
end that's his one snap as a tight end
and it was you know something i could
have done
um
i i i i'm always conflicted with tebow
because i feel like he's the pawn in the
broader scheme to separate people from
their money that people know
whether it's the mets whether it's the
jaguars right they know this guy's gonna
sell jerseys he's gonna sell tickets
he's gonna create excitement but at the
same time he doesn't deserve the spot
his abilities do not merit a job with
the jaguars just like it didn't merit a
spot on the triple a club of the new
york mets that he was playing for
there's somebody else who should have
had that job based on merit this proves
that it's not always about merit it's
about money and with tebow it's the
money that is driving this that's why
the jaguars are doing it they're trying
to sell tickets they're trying to fill
the stadium they're going to sell plenty
of jerseys with whatever number tebow
wears and i have a feeling he'll be back
in 15 once they get rid of gardner
minshew and that's just the way it is
and
look is it right is it wrong i don't
know but it's not surprising it's not
surprising to me at all chris no it's
it's not surprising to me listen you
know it's a weird subject altogether it
is you know again like i i know tim
tebow's a really good guy a hundred
percent it's not personal to him but
it's like yeah it's weird i got mixed
feelings about it a little bit i do
you know
one hey i understand it i get it like
you said there's the financial aspect
the the media attention everything about
it jacksonville tim tebow he's a legend
in that part of the country i was
talking to somebody down in jacksonville
yesterday mike and they literally said
i think the people here are more excited
about tebow being signed than us
drafting trevor lawrence like that that
is amazing exactly that is amazing right
so it just it's it's that's where
you know again so i understand it it's
business there's a personal relationship
with urban meyer and tim tebow you know
yes he's going to get people to go to
training camp and we're going to have
more interviews with jacksonville
because tebow's there and you're right
it's going to sell jerseys
but
i also come back to like all of that and
i know tebow's worked hard and i'm not
trying to like take credit away but i
also think it has to be stated like if
this isn't the example of like white
privilege in sports and i don't know
really what is i mean i really don't
like i mean this is the this is the you
you said it
i mean
we the quarterback thing didn't work he
was very fortunate to get as many you
know at bats at that as there was
no business really being on a
professional baseball team gets to do
that now you get to come back without
playing football you know in years and
you've never played this position other
than that one snap that was really ugly
and
you're just gonna get thrown on the team
right away boom bam yep go ahead you
know and there's all these other people
out there in the world who have been
playing tight end and doing that that's
where i get conflicted here and i don't
mean to make it personal against tim
tebow but it's just about a broader i i
don't know it it bothers me i guess to a
degree from that aspect
and and here's the point yeah
look
he needs to have the self-awareness to
realize
what's going on here and i think we can
impute to him sufficient self-awareness
that no matter what he says you know i'm
just going to go work hard and i'm i'm
just really trying to help the team and
i'm really excited to be here and it's
great to be back
at some point you got to realize you're
being played at some point you got to
realize that they are just using you as
a vehicle to make as much money as they
can that they have a publicity component
to this
and
either is he playing them too mike
though because he's getting the he's
getting the
the publicity and he still gets to be
tim tebow and you know i don't know
he'll probably be on pre-game major
league baseball shows and the pregame
college football show and the pre-game
nfl show there's like tim bebo knows
everything but you know that's where it
works for him too
yeah you know there's a point where the
wide-eyed pollyanna routine has to yield
to the fact that there has to be at some
level a cunning business person who
knows how to take full advantage of
everything that's fallen his way because
he he hasn't just disappeared no and and
and he he always keeps his foot in
something so
uh you know either he's got agents who
just kind of lead him around and don't
really explain to him why he's doing
what he's doing or he understands
exactly what's happening and chris my
prediction is that he'll he'll make
the
the practice squad and he'll be one of
the guys that gets called up every week
there's those two spots
where you can add two guys to the to the
55-man roster every week and he's gonna
and he's gonna there you know from time
to time maybe for the home games he'll
dress maybe they'll find a way to get
him onto the field to have some gimmick
play and you know he'll get a chance to
have the football bounce off his helmet
in the end zone maybe at some point uh
during the season but they'll find a way
to do just enough to keep him around
just enough to justify all the jerseys
they're going to sell because the last
thing you're going to do if you're
trying to establish an unprecedented
bond with jacksonville
is sell a bunch of tim tebow jerseys and
then cut him
he's he's going to be on the team he's
not going to be on the 90-man roster
simply so he can be cut labor day
weekend i i can only imagine that
they're doing this with every intention
of giving him roster spot number 53 or
54 or 55 when they do that practice
squad elevation thing and you can do it
every week you can do it non-stop you
can keep bringing him up and sending him
down because it's not like anyone else
is going to claim him on waivers after
the trade deadline when you've brought
him up multiple times and he's got to
pass through waivers before it goes back
to the practice squad no one's going to
pluck him away from the jaguars at this
point man
i don't i don't know i don't
um
i you make a valid point you do
i don't know if i'm willing to go there
yet that he makes you know the roster or
gets even that spot i i guess what i'm
because what i'm really saying is if i'm
gonna play her at a locker room and that
happens like i'm going what are we doing
here what what the guy's what he's made
the team he's on the dress what i've
been playing tight end in the nfl or in
college and i'm not getting the
opportunity to get the dress and all
that i mean that that to me listen it's
a slippery slope they better be careful
that's when you start to get to play to
favorites and things like that and the
locker room starts to watch the head
coach and go man what's the deal why
does this guy get the benefit of the
doubt for everything why do these three
or four guys never get in trouble or
yell i don't know that i don't i really
don't i'm i'm gonna say i'd be shocked
if he's on the roster i i mean i don't
know what to say here but no i don't
really think he really deserves the shot
to play in the nfl i don't it's out of
the tight end i understand it i
understand all the circumstances around
it and i don't want it to be personal
against him but yeah it gives me weird
feelings uh and i don't think it
necessarily looks right with other
people that are out there on the street
and other people who yeah haven't got
other opportunities and things like that
how much of this do you think is urban
meyer
thinking that he'll say whatever needs
to be said
he'll he'll smooth it out
he'll get guys to buy in and he believes
that tebow will be
a great example of hard work of effort
of leadership and he's a nice guy
you know that's the thing the guys in
the locker room may look at him funny
and then he comes in
and he he does that thing where
everybody ends up liking him
so
you know yeah you can say oh tim tebow i
don't want that guy in here and he comes
in he's smiling he's happy and he's you
know he's working hard and he's he's
saying all the right things and you feel
guilty
i feel guilty saying that tim tebow
shouldn't have gone and done an extended
five-year fantasy baseball camp and that
he has no business being on the nfl team
but you know what he has no business
being on an nfl team there's other guys
out there who are more talented who have
played the position it's been nine years
since he was last in the nfl and don't
get me started on the name of the guy
that starts with a k who's trending on
twitter because people are figuring out
the disparity well that's not going to
be right now right the best argument now
against anyone considering colin
kaepernick is what he's been out of
football for 2017 2018 2019 2020. okay
he hasn't played in four seasons yeah we
can't let we can't get that wipe that
excuse away there's been there's been
four years of quarterbacks who have come
to the nfl this guy hasn't done anything
by way of playing football and and and
now you got a guy
13 14 15 16 on top of 17 18 19 20 and
nobody's batting an eye oh yeah come on
back tim tebow i know that's the
disparity that people are looking at
saying what the hell is wrong with this
picture what's wrong with this picture
yeah i know listen i
i'm in the kitchen last night with the
wife telling her this story and it's i'm
sure she i'm sure she appreciates being
referred to as the wife well we go ahead
we have an old school relationship
that's why we talk i mean that's the way
we are i mean we are we're all white
yeah sorry so she doesn't take offense
to that i wouldn't call her that if that
was if that was the case but like it's
the first thing that came up with the
wife was like
what you know because yeah
she brought it up she's a little bit
like oh man this isn't going to look
good she's like with kaepernick in that
situation and i was like i know right
yeah that's i knew you knew this was
going to come about because you're right
that was the excuse for kaepernick you
know the real excuse of course is teams
don't want to deal with the criticism
and everything like that but that was
one of the ones they hid behind without
having to say that and now a guy like
tebow that's why i got into like what
i've originally said this is about as a
white privilege of a of a sports move is
there is i mean this is the poster child
hey here's a guy who's you know played
high school in this area college in this
area you know fits the culture and the
ethics of being you know religious and
christian and everything about the area
all of those type of things oh so what
he's failed a bunch of times you know
he's a good guy look at him smile you
know look at all that oh he's down there
praying by himself it doesn't matter let
him try out for the team again let him
try out for the team again let him try
out that just that that's where he
doesn't sit well and that's where it it
bothers me and i get i don't want to
make it personal to him i'd want that to
be known it's just the whole optics of
the situation that yeah i don't think
are right here
there is
a a segment
of the nfl fan base who believes to this
day that
tim tebow was drummed out of the nfl
a decade ago because of his christianity
get the hell out of here it's ridiculous
the hell out of here
he was drummed out of the nfl because
he's not good enough and because he had
such a following of tebow maniacs that
if anyone had put him on a depth chart
at number three there instantly would
have been a push to make him number one
the same thing that happened in denver
remember when he leapfrogged would he
leapfrog brady quinn and kyle he brought
somebody to number one kyle orton he he
it was just okay hey we're putting this
guy on the field guys too popular
putting him on the field and uh you know
horrible practice players so he's not
gonna make your other players any better
no between monday and sunday when he's
out on the field because every ball is
gonna be skipped or thrown over their
heads because that's just what he wants
he's just not a very accurate passer
there's just something that happens
in the fourth quarter of a close game
this magic that he's unable to harness
at any other time what whatever urgency
he taps into
when the clock is ticking down to zero
in the fourth quarter i don't know why
he never figured to try to tap into that
urgency at any other time if he could
have played like that all the time if he
could have practiced like that all the
time he still would have been in the nfl
but the bottom line is he wasn't good
enough and coaches and and gm's didn't
want the distraction that was going to
come from all the the tebow fans right
wearing them out to play a guy who
didn't deserve to be on the field right
right i mean listen you can sit here and
argue i mean again it it's it's
you know i mean really he was not a
starting quarterback in the nfl
yeah it kind of fell into that way and
of course it wasn't because of the
following and all the things you said
like nobody was going to let that die
including tim tebow no matter where he
went but i mean he wasn't pushed out of
the league because of christianity most
the league is christianity i mean that's
what the league is i mean there's
there's
people to pray with and everything in
almost every locker room that's the way
it is so that's definitely not why he
was pushed out of the league absolutely
not he
got more chances in the league than
probably he deserved and you know again
you're right i mean the fourth quarter
magic and all that but here's what i'll
always argue with that this is where
people drop the ball they go whoa he did
go to the playoffs i know they went to
the playoffs they won a game against
pittsburgh with big ben hopping around
on one leg all of that but that team was
like a super bowl team could have won
the super bowl that's how good they were
there was a problem at quarterback so
they just got into the playoffs but like
again the next year it was
peyton manning there and damn are they
going to ever lose a game and 14 and 2
or 13-3 number one seed in the playoffs
and all those type of things too
so competitor tough i get all of that
but yeah like you said it's it's eight
it's nine years later and it's a
different position and i do think it's
gonna it's gonna rub everybody wrong in
the nfl really every player play there
yeah that jets game play the thursday
night game that prompted the john elway
holy crap how am i going to get rid of
this guy now
clapping remember they cut the elway and
he's like whole oh no maybe he might be
stuck with them
please peyton manning please peyton
manning um
and yeah
i
meyer went through the thing earlier
this year with chris doyle yeah the
strength and conditioning coach from
iowa who had been involved in
controversies there
racial issues and meyer got shouted down
and within a matter of two or three days
doyle was out
they very carefully calculated this
urban meyer tim tebow reunion look it
was the thing that came out just a few
hours before the start of the draft it
got nudged aside by aaron rodgers and
it's continued to percolate ever since
and everyone's had a chance to kind of
get used to it i don't know what kind of
blowback they're going to get they
should get blowback for it
and and i will will it cause urban meyer
to double down
or will it cause him to say yeah we're
going to give this guy an objective
evaluation if he's not good enough he's
not he's just not going to make the team
i have a feeling there's a chance he
he'll double down
and and he'll he'll find a way to
exercise his discretion in a way that
keeps team tim tebow around in lieu of
the fact that there are others out there
better suited to play tight end for the
jaguars or anyone else yeah i i i mean
they're not going to get blow back in
that area right so they just have to
wait for like the national media to die
down a little bit which is going to be a
day or two and this will go go away but
yeah you know again you know you'd
started the conversation a little with
like how yeah is tebow fall into this or
does he plan these things i mean the
fact that that was put out there right
before the draft i mean yeah it's all
part of this machine
of like yes let's keep it out there
let's keep it going here we go and i
think you're right they put it out there
one to you know get people talking about
it and get people to digest it a little
bit and now they can make the move but
they're going to get no blowback in the
jacksonville area none so that's where i
don't know if there's going to be any
other pressure on urban meyer really out
of this other than just listen to people
like us here for the day or two to talk
about it did this kaepernick thing
it's going right let's see let's see
what kind of traction it gets that
that's not going last jaguar's thing
yeah it's a broader nfl issue right that
you're bringing back a guy who hasn't
been in the in the game in a regular
season game in nine years you're
bringing him back to play a position
he's never played before other than the
snap that we showed 25 times
one after another earlier but and i have
a feeling it's going to come up again
but um
there's a disconnect there and we'll
we'll see we'll see if there's an
appetite for continuing to push that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports